Wow.
Wow, long time.
No shame.
Welcome back.
I'm catching up on streams since I've been bedridden with Tommy Hort.
Oh, Avni.
Feel better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Welcome, guys.
Hello, hello.
Is there... Hold on, let me move my mic a little.
Oh, gosh.
I saw a Gengar pin at Artist Alley today.
It reminded me of you.
Very silly energy.
Did you get it?
Hello, hello, hello.
Intimate mic.
I'm so close.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me now?
Can you hear me like this?
This is not an ASMR stream.
Hopefully it sounds okay, though.
This is Cabin Factory, but it has no... It has no sound, so I don't actually know how to...
Welcome back, Minto.
What do you mean, welcome back?
Wow!
Jay, thank you!
Really wish I could go to the concert, but work.
Hope you have an amazing concert, Minky.
Thank you!
I'm so nervous.
And I saw that this game doesn't seem to be very long.
So I was like, oh, maybe to get rid of some nerves, I can...
What the?
I can do a karaoke or something.
I don't know.
I don't know, gosh.
I was... Oh my gosh.
I'm nervous, too, for some reason.
Why are you nervous?
I feel like... I don't have a heart, you know, because I'm dead, but I feel like this, like...
In my chest.
Like I'm so nervous in my chest.
It's going...
I'm so nervous.
If you're nervous, we get nervous.
No!
You have to be... You have to be confident, so I feel confidence.
Astro Bot.
I know!
Astro Bot!
Come back with the concert, Minto.
Wish I could watch the concert live, but I look forward to the snippets you and Doki pick out.
I think there will be people recording, too, so...
You know, not to say that you shouldn't go if you can, obviously, but like, you know...
I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe we should sing that in the karaoke.
Good luck, Minto.
You're going to do great.
Thank you.
Chibi Minto time.
No.
No Ace Combat.
No Delta, but I was like, it's the game awards.
They're probably not going to...
They're not going to talk about Delta, huh?
Hi, Doug.
I did get it.
I was thinking about gifting it to you, but the policy says paper gifts only.
It said letters.
If you can slip it into an envelope.
I'm just saying.
But no, you should.
You should keep it.
I could go get it myself if I wanted to.
I could go haunt over there.
We got the Porsche Spaceship.
Oh my God.
I laughed.
I literally LOL'd.
I laughed out loud when I saw the Porsche Spaceship.
And I was like... And then it showed the Sony, like, CDs.
And I was like, this isn't a Kojima game, is it?
But then I was like, oh, it's Naughty Dog.
It's a Naughty Dog.
I wish I could attend the concert festa Black Winter.
I know you'll do amazing.
Thank you, Hoopties.
And Dracos, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Naughty Dog.
Naughty Dog Dog.
No.
I really thought it was Kojima from the product placement.
I know.
Well, I don't know.
He would... If he could work with Porsche, he would though, you know.
Probably.
Anyway, should we play Cabin Factory?
We'll talk more when I do the karaoke, right?
Oh my god, I'm old!
Welcome to the Cabin Factory Corporation.
At the Cabin Factory, we pride ourselves in creating the best hyper-realistic horror cabins for the movie and theme park industries.
Starting today, you will be one of our cabin inspectors.
Congratulations.
Due to a recent legal dispute that falsely claims some of our cabins are haunted, it's now mandatory to inspect every cabin to ensure the safety of all users.
It's important to highlight this claim is untrue and that we have had zero cases of serious anomalies proven to be the corporation's fault.
We're positive you will carry out these inspections thoroughly and professionally.
From the whole Cabin Factory Corporation family, have a wonderful first day as a cabin inspector.
By entering this elevator, you have accepted all the terms of your contract, which may be updated without notice.
Oh.
Hold on, I'm going to change, maybe, actually, this might be okay.
Oh, it's really dark.
It's really dark.
Oh, I can't see.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
The void.
Inspect the whole cabin.
If haunted, turn back immediately and press Danger.
If safe, press Clear.
Any movement means the cabin is haunted.
Gosh, this game.
Stop spooking me.
I didn't press Start.
Can you hear me, you think, reading the instructions?
Now this looks cozy.
Do you see me in it?
Haunted.
Just kidding.
Oh.
What's that noise?
Why does the cabin come with it's own wind sound effects?
Why does it come with it's own wind sound effects?
Guys, I think I'm spooked out.
No, I'm scared.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
Xenofold, is it your birthday?
Sorry I messed up.
I don't like it.
Oh god.
Oh no!
Oh my god, I feel like I'm in phasmophobia.
Why is it so dusty?
Does that count as movement?
Hey there demons.
Why is there an old lady?
The first one surely wouldn't be haunted, right?
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Coward?
I am.
I am just a ghost maid.
I don't deal with any cabin ghosts.
Can you die in this game?
I wonder.
Thank you SuperChat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Is he supposed to be there?
There is a man in my house.
He is not moving.
Hold on one second.
That's the cabin guy.
Oh god.
How big is this cabin?
Oh my god.
There is an upstairs?
That doesn't open.
He is eating a croissant and apple.
Oh I'm scared.
Guys I'm scared.
I don't know why this game is getting to me so much.
Maybe because it feels like Phasmophobia and Phasmophobia scares me.
That's not a croissant.
I mean what are you...a peel?
But it's bread.
It's bread.
For sure.
My birthday is on Sunday.
I'll be in my 30's.
31.
Can I get a happy birthday?
So early?
Let me get out of the cabin.
What if I just say clear.
Shift to run.
Oh god.
Sunday is tomorrow.
No, it's Saturday.
Tomorrow for me.
Happy birthday!
Early birthday.
Ok, back to being scared.
You know what?
I'm just going to say clear.
We are going off ghost intuition.
I don't like how it gets so dark.
Nervous for tomorrow?
Maybe that's what's making me more nervous.
Because I'm scared of tomorrow.
I baked cookies for the line.
The lines for Vtuber panels today were massive.
Am I hearing something?
Just the wind.
Guys, I made a mistake.
I'm scared of this game.
Wait!
I need the moral support.
Scary alert.
No, I'm so scared.
Oh gosh, I'm so scared.
Let me see.
Let me see if anybody is available.
This game doesn't look very scary at all.
What are you saying?
I'm scared!
I've messaged Matara.
She's the only person I can think of.
She's the only person I can think of that might be available.
Use the snake soundboard.
One good thing.
Yesterday's winter sale means Ace Combat 7 is on sale again.
Let's go!
It's so cheap.
Six dollars.
Matara is...
Matara is typing.
No!
She's not available!
Do at everybody.
At who?
Oh my god.
Nobody is available.
Kiwawa?
I don't know.
It might be difficult for her.
That game went back now.
Excited for your performance tomorrow.
Oh my gosh!
See you there!
I don't know why.
I'm so sorry you guys.
I didn't think that this game would be like this to me.
I'm so...
I was like, oh yeah, fast game.
Not fast if I'm a big ass baby about it.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Wait.
Did the door open from...
Oh, nevermind.
Guys, I'm too much of a baby.
There is no crouching in this.
Video game door.
I said, look behind you.
You know what?
You're right.
If Matara could do... Oh my god, that lady is staring at me.
If Matara could do PT, I can do this too, right?
I thought you were a Baachan.
What do you mean?
What does it have to do with anything?
I say it's clear.
Oops.
Wait.
Oh, so that was haunted.
By me, probably.
I was able to catch stream.
It's your birthday.
FarCry, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear FarCry.
PB&J.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
I wish I was playing Exit 8 right now.
I was feeling it's not as scary of a game.
Oh god, you can do...
That was PT.
Guys, I have to be able to sleep tonight.
I have to be able to sleep tonight so I have enough rest for the concert tomorrow.
It's a cabin.
What?
I think it's haunted.
Danger.
What?
What do you mean boop boop?
That was not a haunting?
How is that not a haunting?
Only movement.
The radio turned on.
By itself.
Okay, what if I played with no headphones on and then you guys told me if you heard something.
Oh my gosh, everybody said good idea, Mito.
Okay, I'm gonna take off my headphones.
Alright, now I'm brave.
What's this?
There is no guy here.
Wait, why is there no man?
Wait, why is there no man at the...
Wait, was the man a ghost before?
You heard something, what did you hear?
Wait, this is movement.
And this is the ghost.
And this is footsteps for real.
I think I died.
Guys, I think it was haunted.
It showed it getting closer to you.
I thought that was... I don't know what I thought.
Guys, tell me if you hear anything.
This is a group effort.
You guys are my moral support.
Oh, maybe he was the ghost.
Nothing so far.
Wait, this door is open.
It was not open in the first time we played.
You think it will shut?
Oh my god.
Oh, no, no, this is so...
So far...
Movement!
Danger.
Ping pong!
It was singing?
OK, I'll watch my VOD later you guys and then I'll be like...
That was so scary.
That was so freaky, right?
You guys hear anything?
Just the wind?
Just...
Not yet.
OK, see this is a group activity you guys.
This is a group activity.
This is good.
This is how we'll make it out.
We're making it through the cabins with this one.
Wait, you hear a goose talking.
She's not letting me out.
Move!
Guys, I'm in trouble.
Guys, I can't get out.
Guys, guys, I can't get out.
I can't get out.
There's a child blocking the door.
A door opened.
Oh, no, no, no.
Give her CQC.
I'm not going through there.
I'm not going in there.
I think I have to go in there.
Who gave grandma this job?
Grandma is going to die of a heart attack.
What is this?
Excuse me?
What?
Oh, no, no, no.
No, ma'am.
Red hot.
Is PT?
Oh.
What do you think you'll find outside?
Oh, whoa.
Is this supposed to happen like this?
Where's the baby?
Why does it suddenly feel like...
It suddenly feels like Mortuary System.
Oh, god.
Oh, it's getting really laggy though.
Oh, come on.
Ganbare.
Ganbare, PC.
I think I'm going to die.
I
couldn't...
You guys...
Oh, my god.
It wasn't just an effect.
I didn't want to move because I feel like I'm in slow motion right now.
So haunted, it killed your PC.
I think actually.
Oh, we're back to normal.
Kind of.
That was actually a review I saw earlier.
Someone said it was kind of not very well optimized.
I was like...
I already put this on my schedule.
Okay, well that lady... Now we know if a lady comes at us, we just run and...
Alright, guys, you know the drill.
Do you hear anything?
Oh, my god, there's a hand under the bed.
That's a real hand!
That's a moving hand!
That was not good.
Danger, danger.
Okay, guys.
I'm surprised I saw that.
You know the drill?
Oh, I guess it's not usually lit up, so...
A man.
That guy, he's always going to be munching on that...
On that bread.
Okay.
Seems safe.
Clear!
Yippee!
You saw it.
I saw it.
What the hell?
I can already see... What is that?
Oh, it's a bunch of dolls and stuff.
Okay, here we go.
Teddy bear.
This is so cute!
Oh, wow.
There's so many of them!
Oh, there's a Minky!
Minky!
I don't see any movement.
This one looks very ominous, though.
Minky!
Any dolls upstairs?
Just this freaky... Oh, there's Froggy Wawa.
Okay.
Go to the basement.
I don't think it lets you in normally.
I think that's a special event.
I think we're clear.
You have to check upstairs.
I did!
I looked upstairs.
You're missing some parts.
I am?
Am I really?
Is the painting looking at me?
No, I think she's normal.
You need to go up.
Why do you guys hate me?
There's nothing up here!
It's a wall!
And a doll!
And another doll.
There's nothing up here.
I think we're safe.
You hate me!
Clear.
Alright.
Do you guys know the drill?
Mutiny?
Why?
What drill?
The drilly drill.
Go, go, go!
He looked at me!
Danger, danger, danger!
Danger!
Love me!
Oh gosh.
Yeah, that is pretty accurate.
Someone notices me, danger.
Immediate danger.
Alright.
What kind of people are buying these cabins?
It says it's for haunted houses and stuff, but they are not supposed to be actually haunted.
They are just supposed to be silly haunted.
Not actually haunted.
Do you guys hear anything?
Nothing up here.
Oh shit!
We need to go, we need to go, we need to go!
Lady, lady, lady, lady, lady!
Lady, lady, lady!
Danger, danger!
Oh gosh!
Oh man, my...oh gosh, I'm actually getting goosebumps.
She ran to you?
No, she didn't.
Are the headphones still off?
She chased me!
Look, we only have three cabins left that we need to get through.
And then I can go sing karaoke!
And I can be happy!
And not scared anymore!
Unless you fail.
The lady is not in the portrait.
I think it's haunted.
But there was another thing I saw.
That was like another complaint.
About this game.
Is that if you...
Say if I'm just like, oh danger right now.
They were like, oh unless you see the movement.
You can't report it.
So like...
Oh gosh.
Wait, do you think she left the portrait?
So no speed running, kind of.
Oh gosh, I'm scared though.
Of her not being there anymore.
He's looking at me!
I think that's...
She's eaten.
Oh she's got her own bread now.
Wait, is this a danger or...
They're not moving.
He ate all of his food.
Oh my gosh, he's got pizza!
Oh my god.
I think this is like a...
Oh and we have another kid too.
I think this is like a new house.
New type of house.
But I don't think it's dangerous.
I don't think it's dangerous.
I think it's okay actually.
Okay, here we go.
Yippee!
Yeah, we got like the house lore.
So there's like the kid, the girl in the basement and...
Oh and she's back in the portrait.
Oh my god.
I'm looking inside.
What
the...
I think there will be extras to this game.
Like DLC.
I wonder.
Was that always there?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
Is that the exit?
I don't...
This seems like... We can go over that way.
To leave.
Okay.
Alright you guys, let me know.
This game is really stressing me out.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm quite stressed.
Oh god.
But I'm doing my best.
I'm doing my best.
I don't think we saw anything.
Did we see anything?
You need to go upstairs.
I did!
Amy, shut up!
The cup is moving?
What cup?
This cup.
It is!
Oh my god!
Good eye.
Good eye!
That was sneaky.
That was so subtle.
That was so, so subtle.
Wow!
Guys, this is possibly our last house.
We gotta make it count.
We got one guy positive.
One guy positive.
I'm so...wow!
I'm so...
Wow, I'm really proud of you.
No,
no, no.
I don't like this one.
But the radio was on before, but that doesn't necessarily mean anything.
Yeah, the radio was in the chill house before.
The TV was clean last time.
Oh gosh.
But it could be that something moved and I said it was bad...
and I didn't get the actual thing.
I'm scared.
I need to see the radio, I think.
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
Guys, hold my hand!
Hold my digital hand, please!
What
if we die again?
I'm scared of dying.
So far.
Ok, the audio is repeating.
I know, I know.
I see.
I think it comes.
It doesn't seem to be moving.
What was that?
Oh, I didn't think that was a voice.
Was it a cow?
I touched that dial.
I think it's clear.
Hold on, I'll do one last look over from the window.
I'll do one last look over.
Any subtle things that are moving perhaps.
A little bear looking around the fireplace.
Really?
Alright.
Gomito!
Clear!
We did it!
Oh my gosh!
We got balloons!
That is our exit!
Wait, we can kick these around.
I'm going home!
I'm retiring!
You'll never see me again, cabins!
This granny is gone!
Granny, don't go into the light!
Finish the work day.
This feels so mortuary.
Oh my god, credits!
Why are
there, like, credits?
What's going on?
Oh,
a narrator voice.
Nice!
Emergency operator.
I don't think we heard that one.
I was unfamiliar with your game.
Peek.
Quick, steal that choreograph for the concert.
It's actually so funny because one of the dances...
One of the dances we're doing is... I actually have a move that's like that.
City murmurs in the dark.
Game of the year.
Grandma's home.
Oh look, that's our froggy!
I like this music.
I'm just a granny.
Is that
it?
We saw the opening credits.
Do I watch TV?
Being nobody.
No, grandma!
Fire!
Oh no, grandma was two days away from retirement.
No!
No, grandma!
You'd think that maybe she was one of the people in the fire.
She said not today, ghosts.
Oh my gosh, she just closed it!
I was gonna walk in.
Grandma said nope.
I believe in a work... work...
Play... work... what is it?
Work-life balance.
What's 30 left mean?
Maybe...
Maybe that's like how many anomalies?
30 unique cabins?
Holy moly.
30 variants left.
I did... enough.
I'll do... I'll do some... maybe.
Let's see.
Let's see what we got.
Grandma, no!
Grandma!
Guys, I think there is...
Wait, that's outside the window.
I'm outside the window looking at that guy who is outside the window.
Wait a second.
I'm out the window and he is out the window which means...
He is in here!
But who was phone?
I have to take off my headphones guys.
Alright, let's see.
I don't care if I die anymore.
I beat the game.
What are you doing?
What are you doing out there?
What are you... actually he is not moving.
Zoinks Scoob.
I'm going to eat your croissant.
He is not moving.
He looks confused.
He really dies.
Zoinks.
Zoinks Scoob.
I think this is actually clear.
What?
It wasn't haunted at all.
Wait, hold on.
Oh no!
I thought I would be able to go into the elevator and see how many variants were left.
Also, very funny that this is floor 8.
Hello?
Oh there it is.
My computer is breaking because of this game.
You don't get it?
It's like an exit 8, you know?
Like the exit 8 and it's a very similar type of game.
OK, you guys know the drill.
Sorry, I have my headphones off again.
If you hear any...
Where did he go?
He's not at the table!
Did he also leave?
I'm done with the game.
I think I'm done with the game.
Oh my god.
He really wasn't there.
He really was outside.
Remember, it takes courage to quit.
You guys, I have a karaoke in 30 minutes.
I'll see you there.
Oh my gosh.
I'm shaking.
Holy moly.
Oh god.
I'm shaking.
I need to calm down and also drink some of my throat stuff.
So, it was he who was phone.
He was phone.
Nozatsu, we'll talk in the karaoke.
Don't worry about it.
We'll talk in the karaoke.
Well, that was a short, silly game.
That wasn't it.
At least I beat the game.
Greta does not believe in... Actually, no.
Greta is my queen.
She believes in work-life balance.
She said, not today, cabin.
Shuts the door.
And that's what we should all do, huh?
That's what we should all do.
I'm gonna go eat an Oreo that has a wisp on it and gain courage.
And then I'll see you guys for karaoke.
Otamito!
Thank you guys!
Short stream!
Yippee!
Bye bye!